we spoke earlier this morning with Anne
Arundel County police chief Timothy L
tamari about the suspect in this case I
think what's the very latest in the
investigation we're frustrated I think
we know what happened we're still
working on a lot of the whys this
morning were we're at a point where
physically we're do we've done
everything we need to do in the crime
scene we have done some search warrants
at at the suspects residence what did
you find we still have a lot of
questions we didn't find any real
motivator we did find some physical
evidence that showed origin of the plan
if that makes sense I don't want to go
into a whole bunch of detail but we we
certainly found that there was a
continuation of thought bringing him
here yesterday the threats the suspect
has a bail hearing this morning is he
cooperating with investigators we are
not getting too far on cooperation when
you held him in jail all night he's not
talking much you know we spoke to a
number of people I even spoke with
former executive editor Tom Marquette
and I asked him he's been threatening
people at this newspaper since since
2011 and I said to Tom sounds like this
guy was a ticking time bomb and he
replied to me that's an understatement
social media he's been threatening this
paper for years should the police have
done more i I don't think that you can
say the police should have done more we
had one incident that's documented with
us it was fully documented it was
investigated the management of the paper
at the time who I believe was mr.
Marquardt and my investigators in 2013
came to a shared conclusion that
carrying action further might exacerbate
the situation you asked a question about
was he on the radar so certainly that
that X that encounter put him on radar
but you also asked about social media
and I have to tell you that policing in
America really has taken a step backward
when we lost geofeedia which was the
collator of information that we had to
search social media sites
so it's tough for us to keep up with
everybody what do we know about the
shotgun he had it is it is a shotgun not
a rifle and it is a pump-action shotgun
so he had to pump it every time to fire
a shot it wasn't a semi-automatic
correct when did he buy that gun he's
had it for about a year about a year so
he recently purchased this yea within
the past 18 months for sure I know your
team was able to get on the scene within
60 seconds very quick response that
probably saved lives and I have to say
that it wasn't just an Arundel County
policeman the Annapolis City Police were
here within 60 seconds with my officers
from the county and a sheriff's deputy
from the Anne Arundel County Sheriff's
Office all made entry together inside of
two minutes to advance on the bad guy
and neutralize the threat all right
chief thank you very much Richard thank
you Gil one final thought here I did ask
the chief if you've had a felony
conviction in the state of Maryland can
you buy a gun he said no we checked the
records actually the suspect did plead
guilty to a misdemeanor harassment
charge but as far as we can tell this
morning does not have a felony
conviction so he may have been able to
purchase that shotgun legally he'll miss
it'll be interesting to hear more about
this particular person and how this all
came about thank you very much Noir